der fall wird thomas hat ja in den usa
eine hitzige debatte ausgelöst dürfen
transgender frauen bei frauen
wettbewerben teilnehmen oder nicht und
eine aussage von jürgen lenders quer
politischer sprecher der fdp
bundesfraktion heute hat mich sehr
wütend gemacht
ich glaube nicht dass trans personen per
se ein vorteil irgendwo dadurch haben
dass sie als anderes geschlecht mal auf
die welt gekommen sind
so dass die aussage kurz und knapp kann
man so definitiv nicht stehen lassen in
den usa wurde diese hitzige debatte von
ex präsident donald trump losgelöst der
sagte das sei lächerlich und menschen
die mit männlichen geschlechtsmerkmalen
geboren wurden dürfen nicht an frauen
wettbewerben teilnehmen wir schauen mal
dieses lächerlich aus dem kontext sind
dass es an der stelle unangemessen
dennoch hat er recht männer oder
transgender athletinnen mit männlichen
geschlechtsmerkmalen haben frauen
gegenüber biologisch gesehen definitiv
einen vorteil und zwar wissenschaftlich
bewiesen 10 bis 20 prozent mehr
leistungsfähigkeit
valentina wir hören jetzt einmal rein
was einem transfer dazu zu sagen hat
denn wir alle am tisch können das ja
natürlich nicht nachvollziehen und
möchte ich einmal gerne das statement
von caitlin jenner hören sie ist runs
frau und spitzensportler war sie und hat
gold in olympia errungen
ich habe von anfang an gesagt dass
menschen die biologisch gesehen männlich
sind nicht beim frauensport mitspielen
sollten wir müssen den frauen
sportschützen ja jetzt haben wir hier
zwei statement einmal von einem
parteikollegen von ihnen vom herrn
lenders der gesagt hat es würde keinen
unterschied machen frau ist frau
mannesmann ob jetzt um operiert oder
nicht und der ja sagt es ist richtig
dass man mit teilnimmt dann als im
operierte frau wir werden wie das denn
hätte ja ja die unterstellung lautet ja
dass alle frauen gleich sind alle männer
gleich sind das sagt jürgen lenders
recht ist nicht der fall herford einig
das behauptet donald trump ist großer
quatsch deswegen sage ich so ähnlich wie
es auch das ioc sagt man muss
gegebenenfalls auch differenzieren aber
diese pauschale aussage nach dem motto
wer als man ursprünglich geboren ist der
darf niemals dann im frauensport wenn
der transfer ist unterwegs sein das sich
ausdrücklich für falsch aus
gesellschaftspolitischen gründen nahe
liegen auch aus sportlichen gründen
hätte verstehe ich allerdings muss man
ja da sagen ich verstehe diesen
inklusions gedanken man möchte natürlich
gegen die diskriminierung an kämpfen
aber in dem man in diesem fall gegen die
diskriminierung ankämpft schafft man ja
eine deutliche benachteiligung von
frauen und spitzenathletinnen die wochen
monate und teilweise für olympia sogar
jahre hart auf diese leistung
hinarbeiten diese an diesem tag abrufen
müssen wenn zeitgleich dann aber
athletinnen an diesem wettbewerb
teilnehmen die von stunde null an zehn
bis 20 prozent mehr leistungsfähigkeit
haben das ist unfair für spitzenathleten
wenn es so wäre also wenn es immer
grundsätzlich so ist wie sie sagen muss
man darüber reden aber so ist es ja
wahrscheinlich gar nicht sondern
deswegen bin ich da sehr bei dem was das
ioc sagt das internationale olympische
komitee die sagen ja lasst uns die
sportarten einzeln betrachten wir wollen
alle gemeinsam inklusion gibt es glaube
ich keine zwei meinungen auch hier am
tisch und deswegen sage ich lasst uns
jede sportart angucken das muss jetzt
auch passieren denn wir haben
glücklicherweise immer mehr menschen die
sagen ja ich fühle mich unwohl und ich
will mein leben leben was ich habe und
transgender menschen müssen dort
integriert sind es kann nicht sein dass
ein verbot vom sport bekommen auch nicht
vom spitzensport wie viel prozent
betrifft das transgender wenn sie sagen
es werden immer mehr also dass es mehr
werden das sehen wir uns im deutschen
bundestag wir haben bekennt transgender
im deutschen bundestag oder ganz zum
beispiel beispielsweise und da geht es
um die frage des moderner wagen
namensrecht und solche dinge aber hier
ganz konkret sage ich weil es mehr
werden die sich die freiheit nehmen die
müssen eben auch die möglichkeit haben
am spitzensport halt wert an eine lösung
entschuldigung wert in eine lösung für
transgender frauen eine eigene schiene
zu kreieren ich sag ihnen nur mal kurz
ein paar parameter damit sie das
verstehen den unterschied zwischen
körperlichen voraussetzungen man frau im
schnitt sind männer zwölf zentimeter
größer 10 bis 20 kilogramm schwerer
haben einen viel höheren muskelmasse
anteil viel größeres herz viel größere
lunge mit dann 50 prozent mehr volumen
ausdauersport springsport kraftsport
sowieso bei mehr muskelmasse das heißt
man kann das nicht gleich stellen darf
ich noch einmal einmal ganz kurz
widersprechen wenn ich mir die pleite
waren habe ich auch gleich übergeben der
könnte ja fast basketballer sein mit
seiner kuh ist und menschlich bin ich so
viel kleiner aber wir würden kollegen
einfallen ohne namen zu nennen lieber
die verbale hängen bleiben die sind
einfach kleiner die werden mutmasst sich
nicht basketballspieler sei ich will
damit nur deutlich sagen die
durchschnittswerte sind garantiert
richtig die sie genannt haben aber
dieses pauschale wird nicht
funktionieren ich habe noch kein
fertiges konzept heute aber das was da
gesagt wird mehr super kompliziert lasst
uns da mehr differenzieren aber in jedem
fall wäre es unfair finde ich von
vornherein zu sagen wie es donald trump
tut trans transgender menschen dürfen
nicht am spitzensport ein bad im hirn
wieder viel also ich teile das
ausdrücklich ich glaube eine
pauschalisierung hilft uns überhaupt
nicht weil frauen sind nicht alle gleich
auch trans denn das sind im übrigen
nicht alle gleich da gibt es große
unterschiede
aber sie haben völlig recht man kann
nicht ungleich neue diskriminierung
schaffen indem man sagt es ist alles
egal deswegen sage ich wir müssen die
menschenrechtlichen dinge beachten
überhaupt die rechtlichen dinge das ist
eine spannende herausforderung aber
bitte nicht mit neuen diskriminierung
deswegen ist so eine diskussion
der eine ist dass der andere das völlig
falsch also ich glaube bei frauen bei
männern und auch bei trans sender gibt
es unterschiedliche sichten und man muss
die sportarten ich würde mal die these
wagen das natürlich bogenschießen dort
anders ist als gewicht heben weil
entchen halt du warst ja
nationalspielerin im fußball für
deutschland jetzt endlich meine frage
wie es denn eigentlich wäre warum hast
du nicht einfach bei den männern
gespielt also wenn ich mir das jetzt so
anhöre frauen unterschiedlich männer
sind unterschiedlich hättest du auch bei
den männern starten können vielleicht
passt ihr doch noch größer du bist jetzt
auch nicht so groß noch nicht sagen zum
beispiel aber im vergleich nicht
trotzdem da spielen können er ist ein
sehr guter punkt in jena da erwähnt also
im fußball hält sich das so ich habe
immer mit den jungs trainiert bis zur
u17 auch auf einer dfb eliteschule
gewesen und damit den jungs des ersten
fc nürnberg trainiert aber ich habe bei
den frauen gespielt generell im
frauenfußball sagt man kann man bis zur
b-jugend ungefähr mit den jungs
mithalten danach wird super schwierig
also es ist nahezu unmöglich mache ihm
ein beispiel das diesen
leistungsunterschied zeigt zu meiner
zeit als ich in 15 nationalmannschaft
gespielt habe hat unsere frauen
nationalmannschaft ein testspiel gehabt
gegen die u15 des vfb stuttgart jungs
wissen sie wie das spiel ausgegangen ist
zweistellig für den vfb stuttgart das
waren 15 jährige jungs das war für uns
damals einfach unmöglich von der
geschwindigkeit und von der
körperlichkeit mitzuhalten taktisch
technisch kein problem aber sobald es um
die physis geht können wir frauen mit
männern nicht mithalten und da sieht man
ja auch ein star heute gibt es doch die
modische these geschlecht ist eigentlich
nur ein soziales konstrukt sozusagen ja
biologisch gibt es gar nicht das ist
irgendwie ein konstrukt ja und das ist
halt einfach diese these ja wenn das so
wäre ja schlimm wenn es so wäre wenn das
sind wenn das so wäre und konstrukt ja
dann dürfte ja gar kein unterteilungen
männern frauen geben sondern dürft ihr
eine mannschaft für alle geben wenn du
es ja etwas ist was man sich mit dem
kopf irgendwie ausgedacht haben sie
haben doch in vielen sportarten die
situation also ich hab nicht basketball
volleyball gespielt und das durchaus
einigermaßen erfolgreich aber es gibt
eine unterschiedliche netz höhe zwischen
frauen und männern aus gutem grund gutem
grund oder wir haben damals auch dann
selbst auch gegen clubs gespielt und so
weiter das ist ein unterschied
selbstverständlich deswegen kann unter
umständen frauen volleyball attraktiver
sein als männer wollen aber das ist eine
geschmacks war im fussball übrigens
ähnlich also ich glaube schon dass wir
dort differenzieren müssen in den
sportarten das wäre wirklich verheerend
jetzt alle in einer kategorie starten zu
lassen und hier ist endlich gott sei
dank dieses in anführungsstrichen
problem diese herausforderung erkannt da
muss sich der sport drum kümmern da
müssen wir uns auch darum kümmern aber
bitte nicht mit einer scheinbaren
abschaffung einer diskriminierung viele
neue schaffen das wäre meines erachtens
nicht in ordnung also trotzdem glücklich
interessieren sie haben schon gefragt
wird diskutieren hofft so oft über
brandt verändern diese probleme wie viel
prozent unter spitzensportlern wie viele
betrifft bis jetzt gibt es darüber eine
verlässliche zahl sind es 0,1 prozent
oder 0 2% oder über was diskutieren wir
hier genau ich weiß es ich frag einfach
wissen es ist ich kann keine genaue zahl
nennen aber es ist ja ein super
komplexes thema war logischerweise und
deswegen wollte ich auch unbedingt
dieses wort lächerlich von donald trump
streichen gibt es transgender athleten
oder athletinnen sagen wir es mal so die
einen recht natürlich an
wettbewerbsfähigkeit haben und dass man
sich durchaus die frage ist nur dann wie
schafft man für die einen fairen
wettbewerb der dann für die frauen
genauso fair ist übrigens gibt's die die
gleiche frage anders rum denn es gibt ja
sportarten in denen frauen männern
voraus sind dann wenn es um
beweglichkeit beispielsweise geht
rhythmische sportgymnastik et cetera da
wiederum haben frauen aufgrund ihrer
genetik und ihren biologischen anlagen
männern gegenüber vorteile es ist eher
so dass einzelne dinge immer zum maßstab
genommen da wird eine frau ex-mann
olympiasiegerin über 800 meter und dann
würde sagen es war ja mein mann das geht
nicht das müssen wir neu behandeln so
wir wissen das und ich glaube dass da
das ioc und alle mitgliedsländer auch
gefördert gefordert sind und wir im
übrigen auch also es muss auch in
deutschland und überall geklärt werden
und vor allen dingen wahrscheinlich auch
nach altersgruppen das ist ja auch noch
etwas anderes ist also etwas anderes in
den jüngeren jahren als bei älteren also
ich glaube ist eine richtige
herausforderung die nicht einfach zu
bewältigen aber diese entscheidung sind
ja schon getroffen worden es gibt ja bei
den sportarten wie zb 15 und 16 männlich
weiblich und gefolgt von tieren auf neue
entscheidung wir müssen neue
entscheidungen treffen weil ich glaube
dass wir mit dem bisherigen wir können
nicht einfach sagen das ist also in
tranchen sinne jetzt ohne lächerlich das
geht meines erachtens nicht aber ich
glaube da hat niemand in der politik im
moment eine lösung aber wir müssen die
herausforderung annehmen aber da sind
die sportverbände als erstes gefragt die
müssen vorschläge machen ich bin ganz
sicher dass einzelne sportverbände
vorreiter sein werden und sagen so
machen wir das und dann wird das
gesellschaftlich anerkannt im gegensatz
zu valentina finden sie beide das ich
glaube fdp und die linke war selten so
nah wie heute
ist das muss jetzt und fdp der selbe
arbeit die frage die ich jetzt natürlich
stelle ist also in diesem konkreten fall
wenn wir noch mal auf diesen fall ihr
thomas zurückkommen sind die beiden also
eigentlich der ansicht dass man sie
nicht hätte ausschließen dürfen dann von
den frauen wettkampf
also ich glaube wir sind beide auf dem
eis unterwegs war offen gestanden dass
ich bin kein sportmediziner weil die
müssen auch noch mal gehört werden an
der stelle also was da muss mehr
fachlichkeit rein in die debatte ich
glaube nur wichtigen das war mein
wirklich hoch geschätzten kollegen
jürgen lenders wichtig eins zu sagen wir
können nicht einfach sagen weil jemand
ran da ist mustafa ossa ausgeschlossen
werden donald fantasie und wenn wir uns
da einig sind haben wir glaube ich eine
einflugschneise und eine aufgabe
genommen und diesen konkreten fall ich
glaube nicht verdienen sollte man nicht
aus deutschland bewerten also das ist
glaube ich dann auch eine form von
arroganz zu sagen das darf nicht sein
dass darf sein in den usa ist diese
diskussion die etwas angeregt aber
daraus müssen schlussfolgerungen litern
verallgemeinerung würdig sind gezogen
werden das glaubt die aufgabe können wir
dann darf es halten sie würden sagen
aussage geht gar nicht aber sie würden
auch zustimmen wenn ich sage es ist den
frauen gegenüber unfair den
spitzenathleten ich würde sagen wir
brauchen die diskussionen müssen
wirklich die sportarten betrachten ja es
ist ja das ist ja dass der
herausforderung von politikern es ist
meistens komplexer und differenzierter
und das ist unser job dann auch solche
antworten zu finden und da bin ich bei
dietmar bartsch die sportverbände sind
daher gefordert